I'm an hour outside of Winnipeg and it
isn't getting any warmer temperatures
around here are easily negative 20
degrees and that doesn't account for the
winds that whip across the plains it's a
cold and unforgiving place to do much of
anything particularly milking cows at
4:30 in the morning fortunately at this
dairy farm you don't have to this is
welding Platt and his family the plots
have been milking cows here for four
generations in July of last year Weldon
did something radical he replaced his
old manual dairy farm equipment with a
system that is completely automated how
many cows are in here we've got about
250 6260 bone in here now then you can
see her are vectors of the robot meter
get that guy he works on his own 24/7
his job is to keep the cows fed when he
goes along he pushes up feed so the cows
can reach it and so this could this
could be happening at 3:00 in the
morning yeah when the calls know when it
comes oh yeah they get excited yeah this
feeding robot is called the vector it
scans the barn every 45 minutes if the
feed level is low anywhere the vector
will automatically go to what's called
the feed kitchen there it gets restocked
with a blend of grains barley and
supplements by a giant claw
that's the crane that loads all the
ingredients like all the forages we
bring blocks the corn silage blocks a
village and barley silage and as you can
see it tells it what to load it picks up
and then I've dumps it in here there's a
scale on here so it knows exactly how
much it's got and then kaki how much it
needs to put in here now it just dropped
a load yeah wants to get a better grub I
gotta ask is there some sort of like
safety protocol on there the safety
protocol actually we broke when we came
in here so just don't come in here okay
that's good for it all this automation
looks awesome but Weldon didn't buy a
bunch of robots because they would look
cool dairy farms are facing real
problems and the company behind all this
equipment a Dutch firm called laylee
thinks automation is the answer we feel
very strongly that the technology that
we produce here today is rapidly
changing and revolutionising the dairy
industry as a whole for our dairy
producers if you ask them probably one
of the biggest things they see as a
potential risk is just the availability
of that labor to harvest milk and to run
their dairies efficiently eighty percent
of the labor that's available on dairy
farms today is the immigrant labor if
you look at the availability just in
quantity of that labor pool there is not
enough labor available in the
traditional markets to support the dairy
industries again it speaks to why we're
seeing a large trend and a growing trend
towards automation and robotics
technology
we have four people that's on payroll
and I would say the four that are here
now have a Seanie instead of an ncnd
Wheldon doesn't make any money by just
feeding his cows he has to milk them as
well which brings us to the second part
of the laylee system the astronaut a new
cows coming in here what's gonna happen
here yeah so as the cow comes in there's
actually a ID collar on her
it'll register and say okay this is cow
number two right and she's due to get
melt what it's actually doing right now
is it cleans your teats with the brushes
okay and then after that's done it'll
actually attach the melting unit on
around 120 pieces of data are collected
every time a cow is milked the system
uses all that data to make adjustments
on the fly for example it can adjust the
components of the feed to address
certain health issues Wheldon can use
the data to make sure his cows are
producing as much milk for him as
possible
did you increase the amount of cows that
you we actually didn't increase the mone
of cows yes but our production is really
increased we're producing way more milk
with fewer people
yeah the efficiency is just waving yeah
that's not even close
Automation replaces jobs but in an
industry where labor is in short supply
automation may turn out to be the thing
that helps save the family farm but
right now Wheldon's not really thinking
about the bigger picture he's just happy
to have some time to relax